Quiénes son los actores que han
perpetrado estos asesinatos Y a qué se
debe este nuevo aumento de muertes
Muchas gracias por la invitación Rodrigo
Pues bueno lo que hemos documentado en
un artículo 19 es que en general de
todas las agresiones funcionarios
públicos son los responsables de estas
sin embargo en el caso decir lo que es
lo que nos compete el día de hoy hay que
tomar en cuenta que diferentes factores
principalmente tres han llevado a que
este atentado se lleve a cabo primero la
impunidad de los crímenes contra
periodistas es del 98% es casi total
serían un periodista en México se salen
con la suya el segundo Es la falta de
medidas protección efectivas y
eficientes por parte de los mecanismos
federal y estatales que puedan no
solamente
brindar protección una vez que las
agresiones ya han ocurrido sino que
también puedan prevenir otras agresiones
Y por último el tercero es un ambiente
de polarización política que ha llevado
a que funcionarios y funcionarios
públicos desde sus diferentes espacios
simplemente se han abocado a
criminalizar y estigmatizar el ejercicio
periodístico Estos factores han llevado
una situación que ha permitido que estos
ataques continúen
hablado usted precisamente de la falta
de medidas federales para frenar este
tipo de actos que está haciendo el
gobierno de López Obrador para intentar
frenarlos y que necesita México para
precisamente frenar esta sangría
lo que esperamos y necesitamos es una
voluntad política por parte del estado
mexicano es algo que no vemos como
mencionaba anteriormente lo que hemos
visto es que se han abocado simplemente
a promover un discurso que enemista a la
prensa con la sociedad la sociedad le ha
dado la espalda a periodistas sobre todo
periodistas que se encuentran en los
Estados en condiciones precarias y muy
vulnerables
desafortunadamente esto ha permitido que
otros funcionarios No tomen la violencia
contra la prensa como un tema urgente
para atender vemos que los mecanismos
tienen cada vez menos dinero hay cada
vez más periodistas en riesgo con más
agresiones y simplemente la ayuda que
ofrece el estado mexicano en su deber de
garantizar protección y seguridad no es
suficiente